So, Mr. Secretary.
It's great to have you on.
Good to be with you.
I always thought
the military should--
once airplanes became important,
the Air Force was invented.
But now we have space.
Why isn't there a space force?
Oh, there is a space force.
They're under the
Air Force, I guess.
They're a space force
under the Air Force.
But the Army and the Navy and
the intelligence community
also build, operate satellites.
Many of them are as
big as a school bus.
One called the Hubble
Space Telescope.
Excellent.
And cousins.
Well, we have cousins of
that that point downward.
Yeah, exactly.
Uh-huh.
But they're really big.
I wave to them, actually,
every now and then
when I'm out on the street.
Good for you.
We'll say hi back.
OK.
[pinging]
[laughter]
Wow.
Was that your satellite?
The one you're waving?
-Oops!
LEIGHANN LORD: OK.
Oops!
So I'd like to
wave to satellites
in case they're looking at me.
Can I believe, for real, that
they can resolve the fingers
in my hand as I wave?
Not quite yet,
but you never know
where technology is heading.
What do you mean,
you never know?
LEIGHANN LORD: That
was not an answer.
You do work for the government.
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: A,
that was not an answer.
B--
LEIGHANN LORD: This is a
government guy for real.
--I may never know.
But you know.
But he may not be
able to tell you.
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: OK.
Or then he has to kill you.
Do you have people for that?
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: Because
you watch any Hollywood movie,
the satellite is, you
know, first it's fuzzy.
You say, enhance.
Which we know is all BS.
But enhance, enhance.
Oh, that's not real?
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: No.
If you start with a photo
that's low resolution,
you can't just say
enhance and have
some algorithm show
detail where there
wasn't detail there before.
Unless you invented
it to put it in there.
That's all BS.
The technology that the
United States military
and many other militaries
have is amazing
and can do amazing things.
And you can get great resolution
from space looking at things
happening on the Earth.
But you're going to
have to wait for a while
before contemporary
technology is going
to be able to pick that up.
Plus, while I'm waving there
has to be a satellite right
there who's looking at me.
MICHAEL HOROWITZ: Right.
And unless it's
geosynchronous satellite,
it's got to be passing
over for that to happen.
Coverage is one of the
biggest issues with satellites.
In the movies, a satellite
is always available on demand
exactly when you need it
to look at the bad guy.
In reality, it sometimes
can take some time.
Sort of like in the movie "The
Martian" when they're trying
to get the satellites
in position
to see where Matt
Damon's character is.
So that was intelligently
written in that regard?
Absolutely.
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: Right.